[MUSIC PLAYING]
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: So my name
is Vanessa Fox O'Loughlin,
but I write under the
pen name Sam Blake,
and that's for the very good
reason, as Natalia's just
discovered, O'Loughlin's quite
a hard name to pronounce.
And obviously, it's
a very long name,
and to fit it onto
the cover of a book
would be a bit of a challenge.
So when I started writing,
my agent and I sat down,
and we had a little
think about it,
and we wanted to
work out a name that
would work internationally.
So now I'm Sam Blake,
but I'm here today
as both, with both hats on.
I'm here as Vanessa,
and I'm here
as Sam Blake, because I started
writing originally in 1999.
I don't know how many
of you guys maybe
have always felt like maybe
you wanted to write a book.
I think a lot of people do,
and I was one of those people.
And I really had
that, sort of always
had that, feeling since
I was quite small.
I really-- I'd write.
I read a huge amount.
And I sat down.
My husband literally
went sailing
across the Atlantic in
1999 for eight weeks,
and I was at home on my
own, long, dark winter
evenings because
it was November,
and I had an idea for a book,
and I sat down and started
writing it.
And this is back
a long time ago,
before I could even
use a computer,
so I was writing
it out longhand.
And I'd just started working
a job where I was starting
to learn to use a computer.
It makes me sound
like a total dinosaur.
I know, and now we're in
here in Google of all places,
but started writing
it longhand, was
going into the office in the
evenings and the weekends
to write it up, and it was a
book called "The Poison Tree,"
and it featured a detective.
I'm quite lucky that
my husband, in fact,
works for the [INAUDIBLE],,
so I have an access into sort
of the police side of things,
and how that whole world works.
And I had this idea, so I
literally just started writing.
And I obviously
thought, because you
do when it's your first book,
and actually, all your books,
that it was amazing
because you just--
I think one of the key
things about writing
is that you need
to be optimistic,
and you need to be positive.
And you have to
believe in your book
because if you don't
believe in your book,
who else is going
to believe in it?
And so, obviously, I
though it was fantastic,
finished it, and
sent it out, made
the first absolute
cardinal error
when it comes to writing
a book, literally put
the last full stop down and
then started sending it out,
and I sent it everywhere.
I sent it to agents and to
publishers all over the world,
and it was rejected by
everybody all over the world,
but it didn't really put me off.
I kept going.
I had an idea for a second book.
And so while it was out there
being rejected, I kept going
and kept writing.
Stephen King talks about,
in his book "On Writing,"
about his rejections
because rejection
is one of those things
that happens in writing.
It happens a lot
in life, obviously,
but it particularly
happens in writing,
and Stephen King talks about
putting all his rejection
slips on a nail above
his desk in his book.
I didn't keep mine.
I didn't collect them.
I didn't want to keep that
negative energy in one place,
so I had them scattered
all around the house.
And I remember doing a
workshop a few years later,
and somebody held up a slip
from one of the Irish publishing
houses.
I thought, I've
got one of those.
It's one of those to
add to the collection.
But I kept going, kept writing.
And I said one of the
things I knew I needed to do
was improve, and get
better, and learn
the techniques of
fiction writing, which
are really, really important.
I don't think I really knew
that there were techniques
when I started writing.
I knew-- we all learn
English in school.
I did a degree in history.
You know, I'd written
creatively for school essays
and my A-levels.
I think my A-level essay was
about bees, and so you know,
you think you can do it.
You read.
Obviously, everybody reads,
so you keep on going,
but I didn't really
realize that actually there
were things that would actually
make the fiction better.
And I did a workshop
down in Dingle
with a lady called Judy Parsons,
and that workshop really
helped me hugely
because it really
proved to me that I could
write and people, you know,
my peers, and other writers,
said, oh yeah, you actually do
know what you're doing.
But it also showed me
what I didn't know,
and how much I
needed to improve,
and how much I needed to learn.
And that's really how InkWell
came about and probably
how I got to where I am now.
So I set up--
I wanted to do workshops.
I wanted to do more workshops.
The weekend that Judy
Parsons, as I said,
was down in Dingle,
and to get there,
I had to fly my
parents in from the UK.
I had two small children then.
I had to do frozen
stuff in the fridge.
I had do all the
notes, the whole lot,
so it was a major
operation getting away,
and that really
wasn't an option.
And with my husband
working shifts,
I couldn't get out
to an evening class
so I was looking
at this problem.
You know, I needed to
learn how to write,
couldn't take any classes.
What would I do?
I decided I'd start my own.
So I got in touch a friend of
mine who is a writer and said,
look, I've had this idea.
You know, there must be
other people out there that
want to do one-day intensive
fiction writing workshops,
and she put me in touch
with some authors.
And because I was working in
event management at the time,
I was able to sort of bring
all those skills into play,
and I set up something called
InkWell, which started off
literally as one-day workshops.
And my original plan was to
do workshops on a Saturday
because that's when you're
free, or most people are free,
and all day, and they
would just be once a month.
And they would be just once
a month during the winter
because my kids are
off during the summer,
and, obviously, in Ireland we
had very long school holidays.
So I wanted to make sure these--
I mean, these workshops were
absolutely, completely geared
to me.
They were geared to me
learning how to write better.
And it turned out, once I
got them up and running,
and I found a hotel, and
I got my method sorted out
because I think it's really
important when you are learning
anything, and when you're
in that type of environment,
that you bond with the
person who's speaking.
So I always made sure that I had
two speakers at every workshop
because if you don't bond
with one of those people,
it can ruin the day for you.
And so for me, it's very
important to get that mix.
So I got my mix working,
and it turned out
that I wasn't the only
person in this situation,
that actually an awful
lot of other people
wanted to do the same
thing, and InkWell
became hugely successful.
I built a huge network.
I had people coming from
Switzerland and India.
I had people coming
from the UK, obviously,
because it's nice and close,
to come to these workshops.
I always used best
selling authors
because I'm a great believer
that you don't lick it
off a stone.
If you get to be a best seller,
there's a good reason for it.
And so that's really
how InkWell started.
And all the while I was
doing the workshops,
obviously, I was learning
how to write better myself.
I think I've probably sat
through more workshops
than most people living
because I've been to them all,
and I sit in the
back taking notes.
And I kept going,
and then I discovered
that the writing.ie domain
was available, and I thought,
this is great.
I have this newsletter
that I was sending out
to my InkWell people,
my InkWell writers,
and in each newsletter
that went out,
I'd talk about competitions, and
festivals, and different things
that were happening and what was
going on in the writing world.
And every single
time I sent it--
literally, I'd press Send,
somebody would get it,
and they'd go, oh, did
you know about this one?
Did you know about this one?
I'd literally get three or four
emails straight back saying,
ooh, did you know about these?
And I didn't, and
I thought, well,
if I'm the person who's supposed
to be trying to coordinate
this information. and I
don't know what's going on,
then how does anybody else
out in the country know
what's going on?
And there was really, at
that point, no central point
for literary
information in Ireland,
even though we are this
amazing literary nation.
We've got Man Booker winners.
We've got Nobel laureates.
We're a fantastic
storytelling nation,
but there wasn't
that central point,
so I discovered the writing.ie
domain was available
and literally put the InkWell
newsletter into a website
and created writing.ie.
It's still going.
It's an online magazine.
We update daily
with information.
It's got features in it.
It's got competitions,
just everything really,
me, as an aspiring
writer, wanted to learn
and wanted to know about has
gone into writing.ie now.
And I love meeting writers
and them saying, you know,
I read writing.ie.
It still amazes me.
It amazed me when
Donal Ryan told me
that he goes there
every morning,
and his wife has to
tell them to get off it.
That's real reward.
And so while all these
things are going on,
one of the things that
was happening with InkWell
was that, obviously, a recession
hit Ireland, and literally
the bottom fell out of
my business overnight.
So the workshop side of the
business completely collapsed.
They were quite high-end.
They weren't cheap, and it
was one of those moments,
for anybody who's worked in
a small business will know,
that there are moments when--
I think in venture capitalism
they call it pivoting,
but it's that moment where
you go, it's not working.
We need to re-think this.
And so one of the things that
happened literally that night,
when I realized there
was no more business,
was that I looked at all
the things I'd been doing,
and all the workshops
I'd been giving,
and the things that were
really working in the company.
And one of the things
that was working
was the scouting side of it.
I had built lots
of relationships
with publishers, lots of
relationships with editors.
And all the way along the line,
I was meeting new authors,
and they had new
manuscripts, and I was really
enjoying meeting them.
But I also discovered that
I was quite good at spotting
the successful ones, and
so I was sending them out
to publishers, and they
were getting published.
I was sending them
out to agents,
and they were getting picked up.
And so basically, I formalized
that side of the business.
I could see that's
where we needed to go,
so I became a literary scout.
I formalized the arrangements
with various agents
that I work with in the UK.
I brought on board a whole
lot of different authors
from different genres who
were able to give people
readers reports.
One of the things that happened
to me through this process
was that I'd met an editor, and
she quite liked the the book
that I was writing
on at the time,
and it was probably book
number three at that stage.
And she'd sent it
out to her readers,
and those readers had given
me feedback on my work,
and it was enormously useful.
One of the problems of
being a writer-- it's
very easy as a scout
to read somebody's work
and be able to see exactly
what you need to do with it.
And as an editor, that--
I say easy.
It isn't easy, but you know,
you can see what needs fixing.
With your own work, you
can't see it at all.
You can't see.
It's so bizarre.
I think it's because
when you write
you have the images
in your head,
and my job is to take
the images from my head
and turn them into
words on the page
so they reform as
images in your head.
But because I can
see the picture,
I might have
forgotten to tell you
that Fred Bloggs that just
walked in the back door
has only got one leg because
I know he's only got one leg,
but if I haven't put that on
the page, you can't see it.
So that, from a writer's
perspective, is a tricky one.
So what writers need
is people to help,
is people to read their work.
And so I have a
lot of authors now
who work for me who do what
we call reader's reports.
So they will read
a finished book,
and they will look at the plot
development, and the character
development, all of
those important things,
and help an author move
it along and bring it up
to the next level.
So that's sort of how the
publishing consultancy
side grew literally as
a result of the bottom
falling out of the business
and is now very successful.
And really, the
literary scouting side
is what brought me on.
So while I'm building
the businesses
and doing these various bits
and pieces, I kept writing,
and I think it's absolutely
essential for people,
or for everybody--
I mean, literally the best
advice I was ever given
was, just keep writing.
Samuel Beckett said,
you know, fail.
Fail better.
Just keep on
failing, and I think
that's what it's all about.
It's improving, and
improving, and improving.
Malcolm Gladwell talks
about 10,000 hours.
You know that you need to hit
that 10,000 hours in order
to reach the tipping
point, and that is so true,
and it's true in writing as much
as it is in everything else.
So I kept going.
I was busy writing away.
And one morning I had coffee.
I was having coffee
with one of the agents
I work with in London,
and we'd found a book--
I'd found book, sent it
to him, and he sold it
for a lot of money, and he's
a very successful agent.
And we were sitting down,
having a little cup of coffee
in Covent Garden, and I had a
book with me on the counter,
and it was a book by a friend
of mine called Alex Barclay.
It was a proof copy
of one of her books.
And he said, oh, you're
reading Alex Barclay.
I said, oh yes, she's
been really influential
on my writing because in
fact-- this is a trade secret--
I'd completely stolen Alex
Barclay's system of plotting
and planning because she has
it worked out beautifully,
and I literally have taken .
She taught me how to do
it, and that's what I use.
So he said, oh, you know,
you're reading her, and I said,
yeah, very influential.
And he said, oh, do you write?
And somewhere in the midst of
things-- one of the things,
I think, certainly for me,
and probably for the people
that wear lots of different
hats in different businesses,
is that it's quite difficult for
you to understand what you do.
So sometimes I'm a
literary consultant.
Sometimes I'm a website
managing person.
Sometimes I'm an author.
I'm also the chair
of Irish PEN, and I
do lots of different things.
And this Simon Trewin,
who is my agent now,
hadn't grasped, obviously,
the most important bit,
which was the writing.
So he said to me, what
are you working on?
And I said, well, I'm
working on this book.
It's called-- It wasn't called
"The Little Bones" then.
It was called "The
Dressmaker," and it's
about the bones of
a baby turning up
in the hem of a wedding
dress, and the detective who
has to find out what happens.
And he wen, oh, I'd
like to see that,
and I had one of those
moments of total paralysis
because this is this
massive agent in London.
He works for a huge company.
They're a Hollywood
talent agency,
and he wants to see my
writing, which sounds
amazing, brilliant opportunity.
But then, as a scout, I'm
thinking, if I sent in my work,
and he absolutely hates it, I've
completely shot myself in foot.
I mean, it's-- what
happens if it's a disaster?
It's like, OK, yes, I can find
other people's, but I actually
can't write myself, but
I'm under this illusion
that perhaps I can.
So I had one of those moments
of oh my god, literally.
But fortunately, we
had a happy ending
because he did I like it.
I read the book right the
way through the next day,
and I'm getting an
email saying, you
know, when are you sending it?
When are you sending it?
And eventually, I did send it,
and thank god he did like it.
And even better, he was able to
sell it, which is also a bonus.
So the first book came out in--
I've never forgotten the year--
2016, I think, "Little
Bones," and that
is the story of the baby's bones
in the hem of a wedding dress.
And that story really came
about because Stephen King talks
in his book "On Writing,"
which for anybody
who is interested in writing
and wants to go that way,
it's absolutely the Bible.
It is the best book possibly
ever written on writing.
It's fantastic, and every
single published author I know
has it on their shelf.
So in that book, he
talks about great story
being the collision of
two unrelated ideas,
how he talks about
how with his books
how two completely separate
ideas came together and created
a new idea, created
the story, and that's
really what happened to
me with "Little Bones."
I'd seen an RTE documentary
years ago about a serving girl,
or a girl who I thought
was a serving girl.
As it turned out, she
worked in a rubber factory
when I went to go do
the investigation-- who
had left Ireland in the 1930s,
and she'd gone to the UK
because she was
pregnant, and she
wanted to hide the pregnancy.
And she found herself living
in the landlady's house,
and working in a factory,
and unable to cope
with the situation.
And what happened to her
was that she actually
had the baby in the middle
of the night in a room
that she shared with
the 12-year-old daughter
of her landlady.
And obviously, you can imagine
the state that she was in.
She went to the bathroom
to sort herself out,
and when she came back,
the baby wasn't breathing.
So she wrapped the baby up,
I now know, in a blue dress
because I went to find
all the court details,
and she put the baby
into a suitcase,
and put it under her
bed, and went back
to Ireland at Christmas.
It is just before Christmas--
went back to Ireland
at Christmas to
talk to her priest.
And in that time
that she was away,
the baby's body was
discovered, and she
was one of the last
people to be convicted
of infanticide in the UK.
And for some reason, this just--
I call them light bulb moments,
when you see something,
or you hear
something, or you can
be at Tesco's looking in
somebody's basket, or overhear
something on the train, and
you get this little light bulb
moment.
You say, oh, that's
really interesting,
and this thing stuck with
me, the baby, the suitcase
under the bed.
And then I was driving back
from the airport then a few--
10 years later, I
think, possibly--
and I put on the
radio, and RTE had
a documentary about a chap
who had written a play called
"The Country
Dressmaker," and his play
was one of the plays
saved the Abbey
Theater from total
disaster, and he had died.
He was a very, very
successful playwright,
but he died destitute in a
little room up in Cable Street
in Dublin.
And what he'd done is
he'd left all his plays
in a suitcase on his bed,
and it was the suitcases
that connected in my mind.
And this is a few years ago now
when I started working on it,
before they built the M50,
and there were, I think,
32 sets of traffic
lights between my house
and the airport, so
it was a long drive.
And on that long
drive, by the time
I got home, I had been thinking
about dresses, been thinking
about dressmakers, been thinking
about unplanned pregnancies,
and I'd come up with the idea
that perhaps the girl, Mabel--
Agnes Regan I think her name was
in England, the one thing she
wanted was a wedding dress.
And so by the time
I arrived home,
the bones were in the
hem of the wedding dress.
Now, I didn't know until I was
2/3 the way through that book
how they actually got there.
I knew they were in there.
I had a really clear
impression of it.
I had the people starting to
map, sketch out in my head,
but I didn't really know
how they'd got there at all.
And it wasn't until I started
writing a piece of witness
testimony in the
book that I realized,
and I remember emailing Alex
Barclay, back to Alex Barclay,
I know why the bones are
in the wedding dress,
and she's like, yes.
And it's funny, when
you write crime,
you have to plot to
a certain extent.
You have to plan to a
certain extent because
of all the things.
You know, plots
are quite twisted.
For any of you who've read
"No Turning Back," which
is the most recent Sam Blake,
it's quite a complex plot.
There's two or three different
storylines going on in there,
and making sure that those
things dovetail together,
and that the right bits are
left in the right places
is part of that
plotting process.
And as I say, I've stolen Alex
Barclay's system of plotting,
so I use columns across a
page and make my notes in it
as I go along.
But often with writing, and
most importantly with writing,
is allowing the characters
to breathe on the page
and allowing them
to speak to you.
And when they do, when
they take over the story,
and when they start to do things
that you don't necessarily
expect, that's when the story
is really, really happening,
and that's what happened
in "Little Bones"
when I found out
about the bones.
And in fact, in "No Turning
Back," the ending of,
the original ending,
in "No Turning Back"
was totally different.
There was a
different-- everything
was different about it, and
it didn't feel quite right.
I'm a great believer
that when you
write you're using
your subconscious mind,
and I remember Joseph
O'Connor at an event I was at
was talking about how the
characters sort of float
in ether above your head a bit.
And as a writer, you're
sort of channeling them.
It's a very strange process,
but it is a bit like that.
It's like they're all
actually out there,
that every character
in every book
is actually floating
around out there somewhere,
and they're just waiting to find
the person to channel through
to tell their story.
And so certainly when you find
Cat Connolly, the detective,
she came to me pretty
much fully-formed,
kickboxing detective.
And with the various stories,
your subconscious mind
is the thing that really works.
And if you're going
wrong, or people
talk about writer's
block a lot, I really
believe that writer's block is
your subconscious mind putting
the brakes on.
And certainly in my
second book, which
is called "In Deep Water," I
got stuck writing that about 2/3
of the way through, even though
I had my plot worked out,
and my plans, and
all the rest of it,
and I realized I'd gone wrong.
And then when I went back to fix
the bit where I'd gone wrong,
I realized it had actually
gone wrong earlier
than that even, so there
were two twists in it that
were wrong.
And I think it's understanding
that's really important.
So for anybody who
is writing and does
find that they
get stuck, there's
usually a very
good reason for it.
As I was coming in here
in the dark this morning,
I'm just starting a
new book, and it's
about some terrorist
stuff happening in London,
and I've just realized that
the reason that's not working
is there's something a bit off.
I hadn't been able to
work out what it was,
and I think I've got
my chemistry wrong.
So I was texting my daughter on
the train coming in and saying,
do you know anybody
who's good at chemistry?
I need to check my chemicals.
So that, I think that's a
really, really important
element to understand,
but one of the key things
with writing--
I suppose with
anything in life--
is to just embrace it,
enjoy it, and to try,
and try, certainly
for new writers,
to get to the end
of the manuscript.
That's really, really
important to try and write
that first draft right
the way through to the end
because very often--
and this is, I suppose, the
scout end of things speaking--
the first three chapters
of the manuscript
aren't really the first
three chapters of the book.
They're not the first three
chapters you, the reader,
will necessarily see
because it takes a while
to get into the story,
and so quite often it
can be-- especially
with a new writer,
it can take a while for
you to get into the story.
And I know, certainly,
"Little Bones"
had a whole long prologue.
There's a bit--
it's now-- there's
one paragraph in
the start of "Little
Bones" in the first chapter,
where an artist called Zoe
talks about this piece of
work that she's working on,
and her family, and
things like that,
and that was the prologue.
That was 2 and 1/2
thousand words,
but it was something
I needed to write
to find my way into the
story, but it wasn't something
that you necessarily
all needed to read
so that has ended up now
down as one paragraph,
but it's just very interesting.
One of the absolute
crucial things,
I suppose, to
understand but also
to know as a writer is that it's
the reshaping and the rewriting
of the manuscript which is
the bit that makes it happen.
Once you get the story
down, you lay it down.
It can be a bit of a
muddle; it can be a mess;
bits can not work, but
it's really that reshaping.
It's the editing,
it's the rewriting,
that is absolutely crucial
to making it into something
that people want to read.
So how are we doing
for time, Natalia?
Are we-- we're good?
[LAUGHTER]
So I suppose one of the
key things as well in terms
of crime writing is plot,
but at the same time,
there's character, which
is absolutely essential.
Unless you have good characters,
why would you want to read on?
So plot-- plot is
very, very important.
Those two unrelated
ideas are absolutely
essential to try and
bring them together,
but story is all
about character,
and you need to be able to
empathize and really love
that character in order
to want to read the story.
Because as an author,
I'm asking you
not only to part with
your cash to buy my book,
but I'm asking you to part
with that sort of six or seven
hours of your time, and
that's an important contract.
So in order to deliver a
story and to deliver something
that makes you want to
keep turning those pages,
character is absolutely
vital, and understanding
your characters and knowing them
is really, really important.
And characters change.
They develop.
They can develop while
you're writing the book.
I was blessed with Cat Connolly
because she came fully formed.
And one of the things
about writing a series
is that when you go
back to the next story,
it's a bit like going to
meet your friends in the pub
because you know them so well.
You know what they're going to
say, and it's sort of the cast,
if you like, is already there.
So it's a bit like writing
a sitcom, isn't, where
you know everybody already?
And then you just have
to apply the story.
So writing a series is fantastic
from a writer's point of view
because you can really
get into the sort plotting
end of things.
And I think, I'm hoping, I
get better with each book,
and I think "No Turning
Back" is probably
one of the best so far,
but literally the book
I've just written, and
hopefully will be coming out
towards the end of
this year or early
next year, is a whole new cast.
It's a standalone,
and so that meant
a whole new set of
characters, a whole new story.
It's about two women
who meet on a plane
and discover that they
have men in their lives
who aren't doing everything
they should for them
and that they can help each
other out a bit to right
the wrongs, and that's a
whole new set of people.
And again, it's
developing those people.
It's getting to know them.
It's knowing their
background and names,
where they come from, all of
the things that make you you.
And I think for
anybody who's writing,
I always think one of those--
you know when you meet somebody
for the first time, and
you form-- we talk about,
psychologists always
talk about, you
form an opinion in the first
30 seconds of meeting somebody.
What is it that you see?
You maybe see the hair.
You see what color
jumper they're wearing.
You might make assumptions
about them from their footwear
if you're a Sherlock
Holmes fanatic.
He was always looking
at people's shoes.
And they're the impressions
that you form of a character,
so it's very important when,
certainly for me as a writer,
to get a feel for
those characters,
to know what they look like.
I use storyboards, and I
go around the internet,
and I go to magazines,
and I find pictures
of the characters, the people
who look like the people who
are in my head,
and they can come
from all sorts of
strange places.
There's some poor guy from
New York who's on Tinder,
and I'm not allowed to use to
Tinder because, obviously, I'm
happily married, but who I
found on a Google search who
is the spit of one of my
characters in the next book,
so he's up there too.
So they can come from
anywhere, and it's just
like a private
reference point for me.
And I find that really useful,
particularly because I'm busy,
because I'm working, and
I'm doing the various bits
and pieces with
the running InkWell
and helping new writers all the
time, and moving around a lot.
I don't get to write
every single day.
I mean, writers talk
about writing every day
and that that's
really important,
but it's not always feasible.
I try and write
as often as I can
and try and stay
in the story, but I
find storyboards are
really useful for me
because I've got a visual
representation of who everybody
is, and I stick that--
I make a big A3, and
partly it's procrastination
because I think as an
author, when you start off
with a story, and you've got
this big blank thing in front
of you, you spend a lot of time
not actually writing anything
and just knowing that you
should be doing something,
but anyway, I spent a lot
time making storyboards.
And I put it on
my desk, and that
means that those characters
are calling out to me.
So whatever else I'm doing,
that those people are there
looking at me and literally
saying, come, tell my story,
and I really, really find
that a really useful part
of the process.
So will we go to questions?
AUDIENCE: From the perspective
of an unpublished writer,
everything looks
really, really bad.
The first question is,
how do you actually
stop writing because every time
you're finished with your draft
it kind of looks
good, but then you
read a book, like you
read a really good book,
and you look at your
draft, and it's awful?
You start rewriting it again.
It never stops.
You send it to an editor.
Editor gives you
back the comments.
You've worked on them.
The draft looks good, but
then you look again at it
in a month's time.
It's awful again.
And the second
question is, given
the first writing--
like everyone
says their first
writing is awful.
It's fine, like you need to
improve and work on that.
What do you do with
your first drafts?
Do you just touch them off?
Is there any reason
to self-publish those?
Is there any reason to send
them to magazines or whatever?
Like what do you do
with the first drafts
that you know in your heart--
like those are your children.
You've worked on them for--
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN:
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --such a long time.
What do you do with them?
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: How do
you give them up?
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: I think the
first thing is to try and work
on your book until you can't
see anything else wrong with it,
until you get to a point--
yes, because that is,
the whole process is, that
every time you go back,
and you see something
else you want to fix.
So keep working on it, and
it might be a long process.
I mean, I said I
started writing in 1999.
It took me 15 years
now to actually
get a deal, now with five books
later, but it was a long time,
and the best advice I was ever
given was, just keep writing.
You only get better-- going back
to Malcolm Gladwell-- you only
get better through writing,
and you only find your voice
through writing.
Writing, also
publishing, is always
looking for what's called
voice, unique voice.
We don't need
another JK Rowling.
[INAUDIBLE] we
don't need another--
well, we'd love to have other
JK Rowling, and another Stephen
King, but do you
know what I mean?
We've already got one, so
we don't need another one,
so finding your voice
and your unique voice
is really important, and
you only do that, literally,
through putting
words on the page.
So in terms of drafts,
the rewriting is vital.
That polishing process is vital.
I think you have to just keep
on going until you cannot see
anything else that
needs to be changed,
when you get to the point where
you just don't know what else
you can do to it
to make it better.
And that can be a
long, long time.
It could be 10 drafts later.
I mean, I'm on, what,
published book four now.
I've just finished and
I'm onto the next one.
I've written probably four
or five complete books
before that, so I'm
looking at having written
nine books of 100,000 words
each, and I still, on the book
I've just sent
in, its draft six.
So that drafting process is
vital all the way through.
So when you get to the point
where can't say anymore,
or you don't know
what else to do to it,
then is an opportunity
to get professional help
and see if you can get
somebody like an editor to read
it and try and improve it.
If you get to the point then
where you think it's done,
it's ready to go,
it's at that point,
then, send it out, absolutely,
to publishers, to agents,
and see how you get on with it.
The thing with self-publishing--
self-publishing is wonderful
because you can actually
find-- you can get out there.
You can get books out
there, those drafts.
At the end of the day,
there's an awful lot
of writers in the world,
and there are only so
many books that
can be published,
and so there's always
going to be more writers
than there are people with
the capacity to publish,
so I think self-publishing
is amazing.
I know some people have been
incredibly successful at it.
The key is that you
need to see it as a job,
and approach it
very professionally,
and understand that the
marketing, and the editing,
and the cover needs to be
to professional standards
because you're competing
with published books
out there on the shelf,
so it's all about learning
that whole process.
So self-publishing is great.
Yes, absolutely,
if you send it out,
and you can't land an agent,
and you can't land a publishing
deal with it necessarily,
Absolutely self-publish.
I self-published of my books.
I wrote a romance, romance-y.
It wasn't really crime, sort
of dark romance-y thing called
"True Colors."
And I'd had another agent a long
time ago, and she sent it out,
and I got what we
call rave rejections.
Self-publishers--
well, everybody
calls them rave rejections,
where somebody-- they
love your book, but nobody
can find a place for it,
or they're not actually
quite in position to buy it
even though they love it.
And I felt that that
was a great book,
and I decided, I'll get it out
there and to see, absolutely,
self-publish it too.
So there's-- and there's
different-- these days,
there are different
routes for writers,
so you can be a hybrid writer.
You can do both.
So absolutely, send it out.
Work on it till you
can not see any more
things that can be improved.
Then get professional help.
Then send it out.
If you're still not gelling
with that particular book,
then absolutely look
at self-publishing it.
The key with self-publishing
is that, again, as I say,
you're competing with
the published books that
are out there, so it
needs to be of the highest
possible standard
that you can get it,
and you can't take
back negative reviews.
If it goes out on Amazon, and
we haven't had it proofread,
and there's masses
of typos in it,
somebody's going to tell you,
and you can't change that.
So it's really important
to be as professional
as you can about it, but
it's an exciting world.
And one of the most exciting
things about writing
is the fact that it-- you
know, can do anything.
You don't know where
it's going to take you.
Publishing is always looking
for something original,
and it's looking
for a new voice.
It's looking for a new concept.
They're looking for
authors, debut authors
that they can build that
they can put marketing behind
and to break you out.
So they're looking for what's
called a breakout book, which
is a big story if you can
do that, and sometimes--
I think it's a book for people
to understand that sometimes it
isn't your first book
that gets published.
Quite often, your first book
is that learning ground.
You know, if we started--
back to the 10,000
hours, a friend of mine
has a great analogy when she
talks about playing football
and how you guys
all learn-- well,
we all learn football in school
and people, and people go out,
kids go out, and they kick
a ball around on the green
outside the house, put the
jumpers down for goalposts.
None of those people expect
to go and play for AC Milan
the next morning, and I
think one of the things
with writing, certainly
one of the things
that I did with
that first book way
back when, was that
when you write you think
it's going to be the book.
It's fantastic,
and it's amazing,
and that you're going to be
out there playing for AC Milan,
but it's that learning
process that takes time.
And you're doing all
the right things.
If you're keeping redrafting,
and you're doing absolutely
all the right things.
You just have to keep on going.
Just keep writing.
That's the best advice.
AUDIENCE: I have a quick
question about your writing
process.
Would you usually
write every day,
force yourself to
or would you, perhaps, wait
for when you're inspired?
And would you also write
in the right order,
or would you maybe write
random dialogue, for example?
Thank you.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: OK, that's a
really good question, actually,
because I'm a really
organized person,
and I need to write
in a linear fashion,
so I have to start at
the beginning of the book
and end at the end.
Other friends of mine don't
write like that at all.
I don't know how they do it,
but obviously their minds
work in a completely
different way,
and they would write a
scene-- like if they suddenly
want to write a fight scene,
they'd write that from the end,
and then something else
from the beginning,
and then they'd put
it all together.
I use a tool called Scrivener,
and quite a lot of authors use
Scrivener, to collect
the bits together.
I actually just used
it for my research
so that I can put stuff into
files and then find them again.
And so if you do write
in that out-of-order way,
then that can be a
really useful tool.
Personally, I write in
a very linear fashion,
and I do try and
write every day,
but it doesn't always happen.
You think about your
book all the time
when you're working on it.
So like I was saying, coming
out of the [INAUDIBLE],,
I wasn't actually writing,
but I was plotting in my head.
I'm was thinking,
trying to work out
where I was going
with the story,
and I think, as a writer,
it's always there with you,
and it needs to be
always there with you.
I remember somebody emailed me
once, a long, long time ago,
and she said, oh, yeah, I'm
going on holiday, so you know,
I won't be taking the book.
I won't be able to work on that
because I'm going on holiday.
And I thought, well, if you're a
writer, you write all the time.
I drive my family mad
because I write on holiday,
and it's my thing.
It's the thing I love
to do most, and so yeah,
so I sit there.
I get up at 6 o'clock in the
morning when I'm on holiday,
and to me it's a couple of hours
typing away is the thing to do.
Yeah, so I try and
write every day.
If I'm not writing every
day, I am thinking about it.
When you're under
deadline, it's different.
I suppose one of
the crucial things
is that when you
don't have a contract,
when you're an unpublished
writer as I was,
you have the luxury
of time, and it's
really difficult to
recognize that because you're
desperate to get
published, and you're
desperate to get the deal, but
you have the absolute luxury
of time.
You can spend as long as
it takes and make that book
the best that it can be.
And if it's not
that book, might be
the next book, or the next
book, or the next book,
but you've got all the time
in the world to do that.
When you get under contract,
you suddenly get deadlines,
and you suddenly find
that actually you've
written book one
because that was fine
that you had that written.
And then all of a sudden,
you've got to write book two,
and then you've got to come up
with an idea for book three,
and then you might
be launching--
what happened to me was
I was launching book two
and trying to finish book
three at the same time.
And suddenly, you
might have to write--
I had to write 30,000
words in nine days
once just to get
book three finished,
which is partly why the end
had to be completely rewritten,
but it's a whole
different world.
So I think, enjoy that time.
And yeah, so when
I'm under contract--
when you're under deadline,
it's much more every day.
It's like, this is a
thing I've got to do.
And it actually helps
if you're in the zone,
and you can stay
in it, much more
than trying to write
bits and pieces,
but you do train yourself.
I think you train yourself to
write to suit your lifestyle.
So I wrote at least 2,000
words of one of the books
on plane to Frankfurt Book Fair.
It leaves here at, what,
7:00 in the morning,
so it was an early start.
And you know, I've
written on trains.
I write in cafes.
I write everywhere, and
noise doesn't bother me.
One of the things
I do do is I have
tend to have a
soundtrack for each book.
So Cat Connolly is obviously
24, a lot younger than me.
She listens to pop music.
She's a 24 year
old, so whatever's
in the charts is her
soundtrack at the time,
so I would make a
soundtrack for each book,
and I'd plug my earphones
in and stick them in,
and that helps drown out
everything else that's
going on in my head as well
as the noise around me.
So it means I can really
focus on the book,
and when I hear that
sound then I know
I'm in the zone for writing.
This book is about a woman
who was an ex-ballerina,
so it's the Mahler
symphony, and I'm
using that for this one,
the soundtrack for this one.
The next book, I don't know what
that soundtrack is going to be.
I'm only just starting
it, so we'll wait and see,
but I find that enormously
useful because it just
helps block out the sound
wherever you are, but also
what's going on in your head.
Yeah, so I think one of
the things about writing
is that it's really worth
listening to writers, lots
of different writers, because
we all do the same thing,
and we all use bits
of the same technique,
but we all have developed
them in our own way,
and there's no right
or wrong way to write.
So some people write
bits all over the place.
Some people write organically,
and they don't plot and plan
at all.
A friend of mine,
Monica McInerney wrote--
I remember her telling me she
wrote 40,000 words of a book,
and in totally the
wrong direction.
It was a complete,
like, all wrong.
She had to literally
delete 40,000.
That's half a book, right?
But in that 40,000 words,
there were a couple
of paragraphs, which
were absolutely
crucial to the
progression of the plot
that she wouldn't have found if
she hadn't written the 40,000
words.
So nothing is ever
wasted writing.
You know, it might be
that you write a book,
and it never sees
the light of day,
but it's not wasted
because you've
used that time and your creative
mind has been working on it.
And you know, it's really,
really vital, so yeah.
So technique--
listen to writers.
Find out how everybody
else does it.
Find out what works
for you, and then you
can draw in and devise your
own way of doing things
that works with your lifestyle.
Some people have little kids,
and they can't-- they can only
write--
I used to only write during
my daughter's naptime,
and my daughter would only
sleep for 20 minutes at a time,
so I think I learned quite
early on to 20 minutes.
And when you've
only got 20 minutes,
it's amazing what you can do.
You block everything else out.
So yeah, everybody's
different, but yeah,
find the way that works for you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the luxury of time,
and I've been sitting on a
manuscript for about 13 years,
so what's your advice
for someone who
just wants to get
the thing out there
but doesn't want to be dealing
with loads and loads of details
like cover design, ISBN,
this thing, that thing,
some other detail,
as most Googlers
just want to get
a thing out there.
They're not really interested
in making a whole bunch of cash
out of it.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So they've
got a day job.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: But
you want people to read it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: OK, so if
you want people to read it,
then there are lots of companies
who do all that for you.
So you don't have to
worry about any of it.
You just go to one of them,
and they're professional.
I can give you the names.
There's a couple, two, here
in Ireland who are very good.
They come back from
trade backgrounds,
and they understand
the business.
But things like, yeah, getting
a good cover is crucial
because that's how a
reader recognizes a book.
You know, yourself, when
you go into a bookshop.
You pick the book up, depending
on what the cover looks like,
turn it over, read the
back, open it, read
those first few paragraphs.
So those things are
really, really important.
So yeah, if you're
at that point where
you don't want to be bothered
with the doings of the makings,
but you've already done
your bit of the makings,
then I think I would
probably just get
one of the companies come who
do that professionally to do it,
and they'll do it
properly for you,
and they'll get
you a great cover.
They'll help you with
the blurb, and then
you can still self-publish, so
you're still doing it yourself.
But do send it out
to the trade first.
You know, do get an editor
to have a look at it
or get a reader's report done on
it so you know that what you've
got there is the right
bit, and do think about,
another story too.
You know, I suppose
that's really
important, is that if you are--
everybody's different.
I mean, maybe you only
want to write one book,
and that's fantastic
because you have, obviously,
and actually getting to the
end is a massive achievement
because there are lots of
people who want to write books.
Not very many people
actually finish them.
But if you are writing, and you
finish one book, keep thinking.
Think about the second one.
Because if you do
get a contract,
it won't be for one book.
It'll be for a minimum
of two, and you
need to have that
next idea ready to go.
It'll make a huge difference.
It will help you with this
awful contract deadline block.
So yes, do keep writing.
But no, absolutely, people can
help you out and get it out
there for you, but do, yeah--
Yeah, it's hard when you spend
a lot time working on things,
but do start-- like if you
enjoyed that process, start
thinking about the next one.
[LAUGHTER]
Move on.
AUDIENCE: You usually
give really good advice
to those who are in the
beginning of the process,
and I really like the
idea about the storyboard.
So how it usually works?
For example, it's like
detectives in crime movies
do this by thinking,
searching, putting together all
the pieces?
For writing, how
you will recommend
to use the storyboard?
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: OK.
So I get the pictures of
people, and then the locations.
I spend a lot of time looking--
because I'm a detail
person, I like
to be in control of
everything, and I'm really
into the whole getting
everything right,
so I would go to
find the locations.
I try and visit the locations
if I'm writing about them.
I try and use places I've been.
So if it's the inside
of somebody's apartment,
I've been to the apartment,
but I do go onto these property
websites, and I
get people's floor
plans, and the interior shots
of different people's houses,
and I put those
into my storyboard.
So it just means that if I'm
writing about somebody going
into the living room, I don't
forget that actually-- what
they can see out the window.
Or I don't forget
that the kitchen's off
this particular room as
opposed to off a different one.
In theory, when you
get to the point
where you have a
copy editor looking
at your book and that sort
of final editorial process,
they'll notice, like if eight
people went into the lift
and only four people
came out, or somebody's
pregnant 14 months.
I think one of my
friends managed.
But those type of
details, I think,
are great for storyboard
because, particularly
locations, then you can
see where your people are.
I've got one
character who I think
might live on a
houseboat, and so,
because we're very close
Grand Canal Dock here,
I spend a lot of time walking
around Grand Canal Dock,
getting pictures of
house boats, trying
to find the right layout for
the houseboat, for the story
that I wanted.
And so I've got a whole
houseboat layout on mine,
and pictures of Grand
Canal, and different places
where they might have
stayed on my storyboard.
Yeah, so I just find
them really useful.
I mean, in film,
obviously, people plot out
the actual story on
storyboards, and they use them
for-- in animation and stuff,
you use them to actually tell
the story, but I just tend
to have a static one, which
has locations.
And sometimes, the dressmaker
had bits of lace on it
for wedding dress, and
it had a deck of cards,
I think, I had stuck on it,
all sorts of bits, just bits
that were just, I felt,
going to go into the story.
It's sort of pooling, I
suppose, the creative place.
Yeah, but I find
them really useful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I think that's all for today.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN:
Are we all right?
AUDIENCE: And I
really appreciate it.
It was, I think, a
very inspiring story,
and it's always
good when you can
talk to a person who has
already success career, and who
can also share some advices,
and give some tips, and tricks,
and all those small
exercises that are
quite useful for many people.
Thank you so much.
VANESSA O'LOUGHLIN: Thank you.
Thank you very
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]